Writing up and counting out those 22 n in
the last quiz took me a really long time,
so I can only imagine how torturous it
would have been if I had, had to multiply
2n by a number bigger than 11. Fortunately
there is a much easier way to simplify
terms than adding them together like we
did then. To talk about how this works,
let's start by considering a term. let's
say, 5x times 7y times 2z. Now remember, a term is
a bunch of variables or numbers, or both,
that are multiplied together. And before
we start playing around with this term,
I'd like to add one more word to our
vocabulary, factor. Now, factors are
things that we multiply together.
Just like terms are things that we add
together. So this term, 5x times 7y
times 2z, is made up of a bunch of factors
that are all multiplied together. Another
way to think of a factor, is that it's
something that a term is divisible by.
Now, we can't forget that in this term
there are invisible multiplication signs
between the five and the x, the seven and
the y, and the two and the z. So another
way to think about this term is that it's
5 times x times 7 times y times 2 times z.